leaders in northern ireland have
condemned a new wave of violence
following almost a week of nightly
clashes
the region's fragile peace has been
unsettled by anger over brexit-related
trade problems with the rest of the
united kingdom
last night protesters in belfast hurled
explosives across
so-called peace walls earlier a bus was
hijacked and set on fire
police said over 50 officers had been
injured in clashes with crowds
authorities have accused outlawed
paramilitary groups of inciting people
to riot
let's bring in henry mcdonald now he's
an author and journalist he has reported
on and written about northern ireland
for more than three
decades henry it's good to have you with
us it does sound like there is more than
one issue that's really behind this
latest violence
what do you think is to blame i think
there are three main issues
the overarching one is the protocol
between britain and the eu which
effectively creates a border
down the rec uh it creates the
impression in the minds of pro-union
unionist people in northern ireland
especially
in the working-class loyalist areas that
northern ireland has been decoupled
economically from the rest of the uk
i think that's the main issue there are
other issues about policing and
accusations allocations that the police
are more
inclined to be softer on irish
republicans who break
covet regulations in for example ira
funerals
and also a general sense of nationalism
on the march
and you're seeing a response to that
night here in belfast
and in other parts of uh northern
ireland this is widespread it's not just
in the city
these are in market times and other
places
beyond belfast and i think it's going to
get worse before it gets better
you said nationalism on the march henry
are you worried that we're seeing
historic wounds being torn open again
well i think very much so i think the uh
the biggest potential is the protocol
which
creates a kind of different uh economic
policy for northern ireland compared to
the rest of the uk i think that's the
thing that
will in that could potentially intensify
violence and
i i make this prediction i think the
next fears
of loyalist response after the scenes
you're seeing now
the street disorder will be some attack
in the next few months on the
institutions of the protocol
in ports for example physical
infrastructure
which may come under attack i think my
sources are certainly telling me that
in belfast within the ulster loyalist
community that would be a worrying
escalation henry we've seen northern
ireland leaders
condemning the arrests saying it's
completely unacceptable what can they do
to stop this
well pardon calling for it and having a
security response
at the end of the day it will be called
off or intensified by the loyalist part
of militaries
okay now if they're very listened to by
unionist politicians
it you will see a de-escalation but i
think everything hinges
on what happens to the protocol will
the british government make it less
punishing on the economy in northern
ireland well
there be less checks at the ports
for for goods coming into northern
ireland than this and the
lesson the impression that this
uh this part of the uk is no longer
it's being cut off because it's in the
eu single market
right the problem is the argument over
brexit and
the eu is poisoning the atmosphere has
been for some time i've been warning
about this coming
and now we see it manifested on the
streets
but i think we could be in for an
extremely turbulent summer
and even autumn and left the thing is uh
and this thing is addressed properly
and that requires brussels and dublin as
well as london
we'll have to leave it there author and
journalist henry mcdonald speaking to us
from belfast
thank you very much